JESSE WATTERS, DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE" ."
AS HE HEADS TO CAPITOL HILL TO
MEET WITH HOUSE REPUBLICANS ON
IMMIGRATION.
IN THE MEANTIME, LET'S HAVE A
MONOLOGUE.
ON OTHER NETWORKS, THE HOLOCAUST
WAS MENTIONED 12 TIMES OVER
THREE DAYS.
GUESS WHY.
>> THEY ARE BEING MARCHED TO
SHOWERS.
THEY ARE BEING TOLD THEY ARE,
JUST LIKE THE NAZIS, SAID THEY
WERE TAKING PEOPLE TO SHOWERS
AND THEY NEVER CAME BACK.
>> DONALD TRUMP INCREASINGLY
LOOKS LIKE HITLER IN NAZI
GERMANY.
>> THE TACTICS USED THROUGH
HISTORY BY THE WORST PURVEYORS
OF PURE EVIL, INCLUDING SLAVE
TRADERS, NAZIS, TERRORISTS.
>> THE IMAGES SUGGEST THOSE OF
CONCENTRATION CAMPS, FAMILIES
BEING CUT APART.
>> Greg: LET'S NOT FORGET
GENERAL MICHAEL HAYDEN'S TWEET
SAYING OTHER GOVERNMENT
SEPARATED FAMILIES TOO, IE NAZI
GERMANY.
TEMPORARILY HOUSING KIDS MAKES
THE UNITED STATES THE THIRD
REICH.
AND OUR AGENTS THE ASSESS.
BY OTHER GOVERNMENTS, DOES HE
MEAN OBAMA?
HERE'S A HEADLINE.
MEXICAN KIDS HELD FOR MONTHS AS
PUNISHMENT FOR BORDER CROSSING.
HERE IS THE PRESIDENT IN 2014.
>> THE MESSAGE ABSOLUTELY IS
DON'T SEND YOUR CHILDREN
UNACCOMPANIED ON TRAINS OR
THROUGH A BUNCH OF SMUGGLERS.
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW MANY OF
THESE KIDS DON'T MAKE IT AND MAY
HAVE BEEN WAYLAID INTO SEX
TRAFFICKING OR KILLED BECAUSE
THEY FELL OFF A TRAIN.
>> Greg: HE IS ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT WHICH IS WHY TRUMP STEPPED
UP THE ARREST FOR ADULTS FOR
VIOLATING IMMIGRATION LAWS AND
BUSTING CHILD SEX TRAFFICKERS.
NO ONE COMPARED PRESIDENT OBAMA
TO NAZIS BUT NOW THEY OFFEND
HOLOCAUST VICTIMS SURVIVORS AND
AMERICANS IN CHARGE OF TAKING
CARE OF THESE KIDS WHILE THEY
ARE HERE.
>> YOU UNDERSTAND THE
CONTROVERSY.
ANY COMPARISON TO THE HOLOCAUST.
YES, THE KIDS WERE BROUGHT ON
TRAINS TO THEIR       BIRKENAU.
MY GRANDPARENTS WERE MURDERED AT
AUSCHWITZ.
MY DAD SURVIVED.
HIS BROTHERS AND SISTERS WERE
KILLED AT AUSCHWITZ.
THEY WEREN'T SEPARATED TO GO TO
SOME OTHER FACILITY.
THEY WERE SEPARATED TO DIE.
>> Greg: WELL DONE, WOLF.
THIS PROBLEM IS BORN FROM A
LARGER BROKEN SYSTEM.
WE ARE TRYING TO SOLVE LONG-TERM
AND SHORT-TERM CRISES AT ONCE.
IT'S LIKE PLUGGING A HOLE IN A
BOAT WHILE YOU ARE ROWING.
SOME PEOPLE SAW IT COMING.
REMEMBER WHEN WE TRIED TO HELP
COUNTRIES UNDER THEIR THUMBS
ANTICAPITALIST?
THE FOLKS WHO STOPPED THAT ARE
NOW SHOCKED TO SEE PEOPLE
FLEEING THOSE VERY COUNTRIES.
NOT EVERYONE IS ALIVE WITH
CONDEMNATION, BUT PRESSED FOR AN
ALTERNATIVE, THEY'VE GOT
NOTHING.
AND WE ARE WAITING FOR ONE.
SOMETHING NO WHITE HOUSE BEFORE
HAS ACTUALLY PRODUCED.
SO WE ALL AGREE SEPARATION SUCKS
BUT WHEN FACED WITH CHILD SEX
TRAFFICKING AND PRETEND
FAMILIES, WHERE IS YOUR ANSWER?
THE MEDIA USES CHILDREN TO
MAINTAIN THE NARRATIVE TRUMP IS
EVIL EVEN THOUGH HE REDUCES THE
THREAT OF NUCLEAR WAR.
AND WITH NO MEMORY OF WHAT THEY
REPORTED WHEN THEIR GUY WAS
PRESIDENT.
DONNA, DO YOU AGREE, I THINK THE
WHITE HOUSE IS SAYING THIS IS AN
EMOTIONAL, POLITICAL PLOY.
>> Donna: FIRST OF ALL, I
LOOKED AT THE PRESIDENT'S
FAVORITE NEWSPAPER TODAY.
THIS IS "THE NEW YORK POST."
>> Greg: IT CHANGED, DONNA.
>> Donna: THIS IS ABOUT THE
SEPARATION OF CHILDREN FROM
THEIR FAMILIES.
WHILE PRESIDENT OBAMA DID HAVE A
POLICY THAT BASICALLY SEND
PEOPLE BACK ACROSS THE BOARD, IT
WAS VERY RARE THAT HE SEPARATED
CHILDREN FROM THEIR FAMILIES.
THIS IS A POLICY CHANGE THAT THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION PUT IN
PLACE SIX WEEKS AGO.
THEY SHOULD CHANGE IT.
THE U.S. CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
TODAY CAME UP WITH A BOLD
STATEMENT.
THESE ARE NOT YOUR TYPICAL
LIBERAL PROGRESSIVE PAPERS OR
ORGANIZATION.
EVERYONE IS SAYING IT'S TIME TO
END THIS POLICY, MR. PRESIDENT.
LET'S FIGURE OUT A WAY TO HAVE
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM.
LET'S BRING MORE JUDGES TO THE
BORDER.
LET'S BRING MORE BORDER PATROL.
BUT LET'S END THE POLICY OF
SEPARATING CHILDREN FROM THEIR
PARENTS.
>> Greg: HERE IS THE ISSUE.
IF WE CAN'T SEPARATE THEM,
THAT'S WHAT WE DO IN AMERICA
WHEN SOMEONE GOES TO JAIL.
YOU HAVE TO SEPARATE THEM.
NO ONE IS OFFERING A SOLUTION.
I THINK WE ARE MAKING THE WRONG
COMPARISON HERE, DANA.
THE ALTERNATIVE IS THE
POSSIBILITY BEING WITH A CHILD
TRAFFICKER.
THIS MAY NOT BE -- THIS IS A
TERRIBLE ALTERNATIVE BUT THIS IS
A WORLD       WORSE ALTERNATIVE.
>> Dana: SOME ALTERNATIVES
WILL BE TO PLAN AHEAD.
THERE IS MONEY TO BE ALLOCATED
AND TRY TO HOUSE THESE FAMILIES
TOGETHER.
OR YOUR IDEA.
EVERYONE GOES BACK TOGETHER ON A
BOSS, YOU DON'T WANT TO BE
SEPARATED, FINE.
YOU DO IT AGAIN, IT'S A FELONY
AND YOU'LL BE SEPARATED.
WE DON'T WANT TO DO THAT.
THE PEOPLE BEING TASKED WITH
CARRYING OUT THIS POLICY, THEY
DON'T WANT TO HAVE TO DO IT.
BUT THEY ARE CARRYING OUT THE
REQUEST OF THE PRESIDENT AND THE
POLICY.
AND ALSO I DO THINK THERE'S A
NARROW PATH.
TED CRUZ HAS AN OPTION, I GUESS
THE PRESIDENT WILL PROBABLY TALK
ABOUT IT.
HE DOESN'T LIKE IT BECAUSE IT
JUST DEALS WITH THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE BUT HE MIGHT HAVE TO BE
FOR WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN HERE.
GET THAT OFF THE TABLE.
MAYBE GET SOME ADDITIONAL JUDGES
BECAUSE I THINK THE OTHER THING
IS THAT WE SHOULD TALK ABOUT AND
IT'S DIFFICULT TO TALK ABOUT FOR
ME I THINK IS THE ASYLUM
PROCESS.
WHAT IS THE BAR?
WAS VERY EASY TO SAY THAT MY
CLAIM ASYLUM AND THEN YOU HAVE A
HUGE BACKLOG AND YOU HAVE THIS
PROBLEM.
I ALSO THINK IF YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE THIS POLICY AND YOU WANT TO
OWN IT, THEN PLAN AHEAD AND
FIGURE OUT WHAT'S THE PROCESS OF
GETTING THE CHILDREN BACK IN
TOUCH WITH THEIR FAMILIES
BECAUSE THE REPORTS OF THEM NOT
BEING ABLE TO DO SO IS
DIFFICULT.
THE LAST THING I WOULD SAY IS WE
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
COLLECTIVELY GO AFTER THE DRUG
CARTELS.
AND NOT EACH OTHER.
IT'S THE DRUG CARTELS THAT ARE
STEALING A LOT OF THIS.
>> Greg: JESSE, IT'S HARD TO
DEFEND SEPARATION BUT IT'S
PREFERABLE TO AN INCREASE --
IF YOU DON'T KNOW IF THESE ARE
REAL FAMILIES, WHAT CAN YOU DO?
YOU'VE GOT TO SEPARATE THEM
BEFORE YOU FIND OUT IF THEY ARE
LEGITIMATELY A FAMILY.
>> Jesse: WHETHER THE
DEMOCRATS REALIZE IT OR NOT,
DOING WHAT THEY WANT TO DO
ACTUALLY HELPS THE CHILD
SMUGGLERS.
NO ONE WANTS THAT.
TED CRUZ HAS A BILL.
IT'S RIGHT HERE.
IT'S PIECEMEAL.
HE SAYS FAMILIES GET UNITED.
WE DOUBLED THE NUMBER OF
IMMIGRATION JUDGES, AND ON THE
SILENT CASE TAKES 14 DAYS.
THAT KEEPS EVERYTHING TOGETHER.
WHY DON'T THE DEMOCRATS LIKE
CHUCK GET ON BOARD WITH THE BILL
AND SUBJECT TO THE PRESIDENTS
DESK WHERE THEY COULD DO IT
RIGHT NOW BUT THEY DON'T WANT TO
DO BECAUSE THEY WANT TO EXPLOIT
IT.
DIANNE FEINSTEIN HAS LEGISLATION
THAT'S ABSOLUTELY RIDICULOUS.
SHE SAYS BORDER PATROL AGENTS
CAN'T EVEN ARREST AND DETAIN AN
ADULT WITH A CHILD WITHIN
100 MILES OF THE SOUTHERN BORDER
100 MILES OF THE SOUTHERN BORDE
BORDER.
WHAT'S THAT GOING TO DO?
IT'S GOING TO ENCOURAGE MORE
PEOPLE FOR BRINGING IN CHILDREN
INTO THE SOUTHERN HEMISPHERE.
KATE STEINLE WAS ALSO SEPARATED
BY HER FAMILY WITH A BULLET
FIRED BY AN ILLEGAL ALIEN FELON
WHO WAS DEPORTED FIVE TIMES IN
THE DEMOCRATS DIDN'T REALLY SAY
MUCH ABOUT THAT.
WHEN THEY COMPLAIN NOW, IT'S
HARD TO TAKE IT SERIOUSLY.
NO ONE WANTS TO SEE FAMILY
SEPARATED.
I DON'T WANT TO SEE FAMILIES
BUT FIX THE LAW.
FIX THE LAW.
HE'S NOT GOING TO END CATCH AND
RELEASE.
THAT'S NOT HAPPENING.
>> Donna: JESSE, IN DECEMBER
OF LAST YEAR, I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU ARE PLANNING YOUR HOLIDAYS.
BUT LOOK PRESIDENT TRUMP PUT IN
PLACE IN DECEMBER WAS A POLICY
THAT, AS YOU KNOW,
ATTORNEY GENERAL SESSIONS
ANNOUNCED SIX WEEKS AGO.
TO PROSECUTE EVERYBODY.
AND THEN FIND OUT LATER IF THEY
ARE PART OF A GANG, PART OF A
CARTEL, TRAFFICKING.
WHAT SENATOR FEINSTEIN AND
OTHERS ARE SAYING WOULD KEEP
FAMILIES TOGETHER IS, KEEP THEM
TOGETHER.
>> Jesse: THERE ARE LAWS THAT
SAY YOU CAN'T DO THAT AND YOU
KNOW THAT.
>> Donna: THIS IS A POLICY
CHANGE.
>> Jesse: NO, NO, NO.
THE '97 LOSS AS YOU CAN HOLD A
MINOR FOR MORE THAN 20 DAYS.
YOU CAN'T HOUSE THEM IN FEDERAL
DETENTION FACILITIES TOGETHER.
>> Donna: KEEP THE FAMILY
INTACT.
IT'S A SIMPLE STRATEGY.
KEEP THE FAMILIES INTACT, AND
THEN YOU GO THROUGH THE VET
PROCESS.
>> Greg: LET ME GET KIMBERLY
ON THIS BECAUSE YOU KNOW THE LAW
ON THIS BECAUSE YOU KNOW THE LA
LAW.
>> Kimberly: THERE IS A
CONCERTED EFFORT TO DISTORT
REALLY WHAT'S GOING ON HERE FOR
POLITICAL PURPOSES.
I MEAN COME AT THE HEART OF IT,
PEOPLE DO CARE ABOUT CHILDREN
AND WE CARE ABOUT FAMILIES BUT
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND HOW WE
ARRIVED AT THIS POSITION.
PEOPLE BREAKING THE LAW.
EVEN IF WE PUT THEM ON THE BOSS,
WHO'S TO SAY THEY ARE NOT WITH
THE SEX TRAFFICKER AND YOU TURNB
THE SEX TRAFFICKER AND YOU TURNC
THE SEX TRAFFICKER AND YOU TURNK
THE SEX TRAFFICKER AND YOU TURNW
THE SEX TRAFFICKER AND YOU TURNT
THE SEX TRAFFICKER AND YOU TURNH
THE SEX TRAFFICKER AND YOU TURNA
THE SEX TRAFFICKER AND YOU TURNT
THE SEX TRAFFICKER AND YOU TURNP
THE SEX TRAFFICKER AND YOU TURNR
THE SEX TRAFFICKER AND YOU TURNO
THE SEX TRAFFICKER AND YOU TURN.
WHAT WERE TRYING TO DO IN A
RESPONSIBLE, CAREFUL WAY IS TO
IDENTIFY WHO THE CHILD IS, THE
MINOR, WHO IS THE ADULT
ACCOMPANYING THE CHILD AND MAKE
SURE THAT IN FACT THEY ARE
RELATIVE AND SHOULD BE IN THAT
PERSON'S CUSTODY, SO TO SPEAK.
PARENTAL RIGHTS.
THIS IS VERY DIFFICULT.
I HAVE A HARD TIME, THOUGH,
ACCEPTING IT'S OKAY TO DEMONIZE
I.C.E. AGENTS AND BORDER PATROL
AND THE PRESIDENT AND THE
ADMINISTRATION, ALL SAYING THEY
ARE MEAN-SPIRITED AND THEY WANT
CHILDREN ABUSED OR THEY ARE
NAZIS IN CAGES AND ALL THESE
THINGS.
THIS IS A VERY TOUGH PROBLEM.
THAT'S WHY IMMIGRATION IS
IMPORTANT FOR THEM TO ADDRESS IN
A RESPONSIBLE WAY.
AGAIN, THE LAWS MUST BE UPHELD,
AND THERE MUST BE SOME PROCEDURE
BY WHICH THEY ARE IDENTIFIED
PROPERLY SO AS TO NOT MAKE
MISTAKE.
CAN YOU IMAGINE THE OUTRAGE IF
WE WENT AHEAD AND LET SOMEBODY
GO WITH A SEX OFFENDER AND
ENCOURAGED AND WERE ACTING IN
CONCERT AIDING AND ABETTING SEX
TRAFFICKING.
HOW IRRESPONSIBLE.
IF YOU DON'T CARE ABOUT
CHILDREN.
THEY LET THEM GO WITH ANYBODY
AND THEN THE CHILD GOD FORBID
ENDS UP RAPED OR TORTURED OR
MURDERED.
>> Greg: THEY SHOULD HAVE ZERO
TOLERANCE ON THAT.
DONALD TRUMP HAD COMMENTS TODAY
REGARDING THIS ISSUE AND THE
MEDIA BIAS.
>> THOSE WHO APPLY FOR ASYLUM
LEGALLY AT PORTS OF ENTRY ARE
NOT PROSECUTED.
THE VAGUE NEWS MEDIA DOESN'T
TALK ABOUT IT.
THEY ARE HELPING THESE SMUGGLERS
AND THESE TRAFFICKERS LIKE
NOBODY WOULD BELIEVE.
WHEN COUNTRIES ABUSE US BY
SENDING THEIR PEOPLE UP, NOT
THEIR BEST, WE ARE NOT GOING TO
GIVE ANY MORE AID TO THOSE
COUNTRIES.
WHY THE HELL SHOULD WE?
SOMEDAY THEY ARE GOING TO VOTE
FOR DEMOCRATS.
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T WIN ON THEIR
POLICIES WHICH ARE HORRIBLE.
THEIR ONLY POLICY WAS THAT
DONALD TRUMP IS A BAD GUY.
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF NEGATIVE ADS.
NOBODY'S EVER BEEN HIT LIKE
THAT.
I USED TO GO HOME.
I STARTED DISLIKING MYSELF.
>> Greg: IT IS HARD TO
BELIEVE, DANA.
>> Kimberly: ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE
IMPOSSIBLE.
>> Donna: ONE BOB CORKER,
ORRIN HATCH, LAMAR ALEXANDER,
JOHN McCAIN, SUSAN COLLINS,
BEN SASSE, I HAVE A WHOLE LIST.
>> Greg: YOU DON'T THINK --
ALL THE ONES DOING THE OUTRAGE
SIGNALING ALL OVER TWITTER.
I WON'T MENTION THE POLITICIANS.
THEY ARE OUTRAGE SIGNALING AND
THEY ARE SO SOLEMN ABOUT IT.
THEY HATE IT, WHICH WE ALL DO.
THE SECOND PART, WHAT DO YOU DO
ABOUT IT?
SILENCE.
>> Dana: DID NUMBERS -- THE
NUMBERS SHE LISTED, THEY ARE
SUPPORTING THE CRUZ BILL.
>> Donna: I WANT TO GO BACK TO
WHAT YOU SAID AT THE TOP OF THE
SHOW.
AMERICAN SLAVERY AND THE
HOLOCAUST.
THEY WERE EVIL EVENTS.
WHILE PEOPLE OFTEN USE THIS TO
DESCRIBE THE PAIN OR DESCRIBE
THE DEGRADATION, DEHUMANIZATION,
THESE WERE ABSOLUTELY EVIL
EVENTS.
WHAT PEOPLE ARE SAYING NOW IS
THAT THEY THINK THAT THIS
COMPARES TO THAT.
I TRY TO TELL PEOPLE DON'T DO
IT.
DON'T GO THERE.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, WE HAVE TO
CALL THIS AN OUTRAGEOUS ACT
BECAUSE THESE KIDS ARE BEING
ABUSED.
SEPARATED FROM THEIR FAMILIES.
YOU HAVE CHILDREN.
YOU ARE A FATHER.
>> Jesse: IN MOST CASES IF
SOMEONE COMES ACROSS WITH A
MINOR, THEY ARE ONLY SEPARATED
FOR A DAY.
YOU APPLY FOR ASYLUM, IT'S GOING
TO TAKE LONGER THAN 20 DAYS IN
THE LAW SAYS, BASED ON THE
CLINTON ADMINISTRATION UPHELD BY
THE NINTH CIRCUIT COURT OF
APPEALS, YOU CAN'T HOLD A MINOR
LONGER THAN 20 DAYS.
THAT'S WHY HE LOWERED IT TO 14
PAIRED WITH THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION GOT WHACKED FOR
AS THEY WERE SENDING THESE YOUNG
KIDS TO SPONSORS OR UNCLES
SOMEWHERE WITHIN THE INTERIOR OF
THE UNITED STATES.
THESE KIDS WERE BEING ABUSED,
MADE TO WORK SLAVE LABOR JOBS.
AND MALNOURISHED.
>> Donna: IT WAS RARE.
>> Jesse: IT WAS HAPPENING.
WE WANT TO TAKE CARE OF THE
KIDS, THAT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING.
>> Greg: I AM TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT, WHAT'S THE SOLUTION THAT
PREVENTS THE SEPARATION?
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE IT OUT.
IF 10,000 OF THESE KIDS ARE
UNACCOMPANIED AND THEY ARE
ALREADY SEPARATED, THAT LEAVES
2,000.
WHAT ARE THEY DOING NOW?
>> Jesse: RIGHT NOW AND SIMONE
CROSSES WITH A MINOR AND THERE'S
NO PRIOR HISTORY OF ANYTHING
LIKE THAT AND THEY ARE NOT
CLAIMING ASYLUM, THEY DETAIN THE
CLAIMING ASYLUM, THEY DETAIN THM
CLAIMING ASYLUM, THEY DETAIN THF
CLAIMING ASYLUM, THEY DETAIN THR
CLAIMING ASYLUM, THEY DETAIN THA
CLAIMING ASYLUM, THEY DETAIN THY
CLAIMING ASYLUM, THEY DETAIN TH,
CLAIMING ASYLUM, THEY DETAIN THP
CLAIMING ASYLUM, THEY DETAIN THO
CLAIMING ASYLUM, THEY DETAIN THE
CLAIMING ASYLUM, THEY DETAIN THU
THEM, REUNITE THEM WITH THE KID
AND THEN SEND THEM BACK.
IF YOU APPLY FOR ASYLUM,
PROCESS, IT'S GOING TO TAKE THEM
FOREVER.
ASYLUM CASES TAKE FOREVER.
>> Kimberly: THEY GET TO SPEAK
ON THE PHONE WITH THE PARENTS.
>> Donna: THE PRESIDENT NEEDS
TO UNDERSTAND THIS IS A CRISIS
HE CAN RESOLVE TONIGHT.
>> Greg: EVERYBODY COULD
RESOLVE IT.
>> Donna: THE PRESIDENT.
HE HAS THE PEN.
>> Greg: HE IS THE FIRST GUY
TO ACTUALLY TRY.
>> Dana: WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
PEOPLE HAVE TRIED COPPERHEADS OF
IMMIGRATION REFORM BEFORE.
>> Greg: THIS ISSUE IS
DIRECTLY RELATED TO A POROUS
BORDER.
CORRECT?
>> Donna: IT IS A STRATEGY.
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S A STRATEGY TO
TRY TO GET A COMPROMISE, AND
THIS IS A BAD STRATEGY.
>> Greg: YOU CAN DISAGREE WITH
THE STRATEGY BUT YOU CAN'T
DISAGREE WITH THE FIVE OF THIS
GUY IS TRYING TO TIGHTEN THE
BORDER.